[Música]
la relación de la reina isabel con
américa latina' fue corta pero intensa y
comenzó pronto en estas imágenes de
archivos se ve a la monarca en panamá es
noviembre de 1953 había sido coronada
como reina en junio y panamá fue el
primer país en ser visitado de forma
oficial en su nave gótica fue recibida
con honores y pudo darse un baño de
masas tendrían que pasar 15 años y otra
vez en noviembre en 1968 isabel visitó
brasil donde participó en un homenaje al
monumento a los caídos y también se
produjo un encuentro que pasó a la
historia la reina isabel le entregó una
copa a uno de los mejores jugadores de
fútbol de todos los tiempos pelé en la
misma gira a la monarca también
aprovecho para visitar a chile donde
tuvo un concurrido recibimiento y donde
también aprovechó para pescar salmón en
el lago pucón
tras esta gira por sudamérica tuvieron
que volver a pasar siete años antes de
regresar a américa latina' en 1975
durante una semana la reina isabel
estuvo en mexico en una larga gira que
la llevó a cozumel ciudad de mexico en
guanajuato oaxaca mérida y veracruz
quedaron dos momentos para el recuerdo
la visita a una escaramuza charra
deporte oficial mexicano y también uno
de los más multitudinarios recibimientos
que la reina isabel haya tenido nunca
por lo que repetiría visita al sur de
méxico en 1983 la que se convirtió en la
última visita oficial de la reina isabel
américa latina'